dernière fois qu'on vous a parlé de
l'hôpital juif de montréal février
c'était au
sujet d'une cible fort ambitieuse on dit
aux gens qu'ils allaient se présenter à
l'urgence vous n'attendrez pas plus que
20 minutes est une promesse on attend
toujours de savoir si le but est atteint
on dit que ça prendra quelques semaines
quelques mois peut-être avant de
fonctionner aujourd'hui on vous reparle
de l'urgence de l'hôpital juif de
montréal mais pour une tout autre raison
c'est qu'on n'a pas que l'upac enquête
et que deux directeurs sont impliqués
dans une affaire de fausse facturation
ils ont d'ailleurs dû démissionner voici
ce qu'a appris julie vaillancourt de
l'équipe d' enquête
les seuls qui ont accepté de dénoncer
publiquement ce dont ils ont été témoins
à l'hôpital général juif sont des
ouvriers il travaillait pour une
entreprise qui avait un contrat
d'entretien avec l'hôpital est rare et
nos actions et d'autres compagnies qui
gravitaient autour alors qu'il oeuvrait
à l'hôpital roberto astorga serre ont dû
travailler chez certains cadres de la
haute direction donc frauciel berdugo ya
tellement aimé mon travail qui m'a
recommandé pour les peintres de chez ses
parents on avait pas entre l'appartement
au complet
et ça c'était pendant votre temps de
travail à l'hôpital mais on devait
remplir leur rôle comme si on était à
l'hôpital le super du goût dit que ce
n'est pas l'hôpital qui a payé ses
travaux une information impossible à
vérifier puisque il a réglé sa facture
en argent comptant une enquête interne a
été déclenché à la suite de cette
histoire selon nos informations l'upac
l'unité permanente anticorruption
s'intéresse aussi à la construction de
la nouvelle salle d'urgence logé dans le
pavillon cas où d'autres irrégularités
ont été découverts tout ça résulte d'un
investissement de 121 millions de
dollars dont 95 millions provient du
ministère de la santé des services
sociaux plusieurs des compagnies qui ont
participé à la construction du pavillon
k se plaignent d'avoir perdu de l'argent
sur le chantier
une seule d'entre elles auraient été
dédommagés à l'époque et c'est grâce à
de fausses factures que nous avons
obtenu 50 mille dollars pour une chambre
des patients et une autre pour une salle
de procédures qui n'ont jamais existé
les factures ont été fabriqués à la
demande du directeur du développement
immobilier philippe castiel les deux
cadres ont quitté dans la controverse
mais leur révélation pourrait
éclabousser d'autres joueurs le
ministère de la santé et des services
sociaux celui-là faire de prêt ici julie
vaillancourt radio canada montréal